Person accused of any crime,
including one facing the death.
Boy Not only needs a lawyer,
but in most cases there's
a need for an investigator.
There's a need for someone to investigate
the strength of the government's case,
the prosecution case against the person
accused and a person who go investigate
things like that.
The person was somewhere else at the
time of the crime or some other factors
self-defence whatever may be the defense,
uh,
that is presented in the case.
There may also be a need for
expert witnesses to be presented.
Now in,
uh,
public defender offices,
particularly capital defender offices
that specialize in defending capital
cases.
There will usually be investigators
that are part of the staff.
There may be social workers,
mitigation specialists,
which look into the mitigating
circumstances in a case.
Some private lawyers will also have
investigators that they rely upon all the
time.
Uh,
public defender offices may have
a budget for expert witnesses.
Uh,
but very often private
lawyers do not have.
And,
and some public defender offices do not.
And as a result,
they're going to apply to the court
for funds for an expert witness.
So let's look a little bit at what the
needs are and then what the court has
said,
uh,
with regard to this,
expert witnesses,
uh,
are going to help us decide things like,
does the evidence,
tell us what happened in the case?
What was the angle of the wound,
uh,
where the people drinking
at the time of the crime?
Uh,
did the bullet come from
the defendant's gun?
There'd be all kind of expert
witnesses are just a few examples,
um,
where their bodily
fluids left at the scene.
Uh,
was there an accidental fire arson?
we know that many wrongful convictions
have been in arson cases because there
has been a faulty or mistaken belief
that an arson was committed when in fact
the fire was accidental.
So it may be very critical for
a person who's accused of arson,
for example,
uh,
to have their own expert in fire science,
come and evaluate the scene,
evaluate,
uh,
the whatever tests were conducted upon,
the remains of the scene,
uh,
to see whether or not we know that
Todd Willingham was executed in Texas,
even though in all probability,
uh,
it was an accidental fire
rather than an arson.
So experts are critical,
uh,
because generally the lawyers
are not going to know that.
Uh,
did the baby die because it was shaken a,
in other words,
the person's accused of murdering a child.
That's a terrible crime and they're
going to be punished severely.
Uh,
but it may be that it was sudden infant
death syndrome or that some other factor
contributed to getting
an investigation and,
and,
and uh,
expert witnesses are
going to look into that.
How long ago did the crime take place
an expert's opinion about how long a
person,
uh,
had been dead?
How,
when the killing took place,
uh,
may be critical if the defendant
was at a certain place at that time.
Uh,
and so the case can be determined,
maybe determined on something like that.
Again,
these are just examples.
Um,
also,
uh,
expert witnesses are
needed in the area of,
uh,
mental health.
Was the defendant suffering
from a mental illness?
Uh,
if so,
what was it?
Uh,
how did it affect the person's behavior?
Um,
was the defendant sane at
the time of the offense?
Not often are people going to be
successful in raising an insanity defense,
but there are times when people are so
profoundly mentally disabled that they do
not appreciate the
criminality of their behavior.
And so there may be a question about their
sanity at the time they committed the
crime.
A is the defendant competent to
stand trial is the person accused,
uh,
mentally able to understand
what's going on in the courtroom,
uh,
to cooperate with a lawyer,
and participate in the proceedings.
It person has to be a
competent to stand trial.
Uh,
is the defendant intellectually disabled
what was previously referred to as
mentally retarded?
This is critically
important in capital cases,
uh,
because a,
a person who is,
uh,
intellectually disabled,
cannot be put to death under
the Supreme Court's decision.
So that is a determination,
uh,
that may depend very much on testing.
Upon review of records upon childhood,
uh,
record schooling and all of that.
Uh,
the Supreme Court has said that the death
pony is disproportionate for children.
That is people who are under
18 at the time of the crime.
And for people who are
intellectually disabled,
that is people with sub average
intellectual functioning,
uh,
that are not held to the same standard
as people that have normal intellectual
functioning with age.
It's easy.
You just simply find the person's
birth certificate and do the math.
What are they under 18 at the
time the crime took place.
Uh,
but with regard to
intellectual disability,
there can be very closely contested
question of whether the person is one of
those people who is,
uh,
intellectually disabled to an extent
that they are not subject to the death
penalty or is not quite intellectually
disabled enough and are still eligible
for the death.
Tony,
uh,
and the other big question,
future danger to society in Texas,
the critical question and whether
it's somebody who sends to death is,
is this person a future danger to society
and expert witnesses testify about
that.
Um,
so,
um,
the penalty phase of a capital trial,
again,
there's a need for
expert witnesses because,
uh,
it's going to be necessary to investigate
and reconstruct the complete life
history of the defendant.
Uh,
who,
uh,
was he his parents?
Uh,
what childhood did he have?
What intellectual or mental impairments,
uh,
might,
he or she have most,
uh,
obviously,
as I said,
may have a mitigation specialist or a
social worker and investigator who will go
out and gather that evidence.
Uh,
but then there is going to be,
uh,
a need for some mental health testing,
Mris,
functional Mris,
cat scans,
those sorts of tests.
Those all cost money.
Uh,
they require specialist.
and so what do you do if you're facing
the death penalty and the person has a
fairly significant mental health issue?
Uh,
you're going to investigated in part
by doing the work of the mitigation
specialist or social worker,
finding out the facts regarding that
persons behavior throughout their life.
Uh,
but there's also going to be
a need for expert witnesses.
Uh,
and there may also be a need
for psychological testing,
particularly with regard
to intellectual disability.
Uh,
psychological testing,
uh,
is going to be very important.
Again,
as I said,
in case states with a capital
defender office or a public defender,
some of these people may be on staff
and there may be a budget for the other
people.
Uh,
but in states where that's not the case,
then it's going to be necessary for the
defense to apply to the court saying,
I can get a fair trial unless
I have the expert assistance.
Uh,
in this case,
uh,
and a case that illustrates this and
the case that established the right,
uh,
of a person to expert assistance
is Ake versus Oklahoma.
Uh,
Glenn Bird Naik,
uh,
was,
charged with killing a couple of wound
in their two children in Oklahoma.
Uh,
his behavior was so bizarre that the
judge ordered that he be examined.
Uh,
and the diagnosis was that he was
probably a paranoid schizophrenia.
It was reported that ache appears to be,
frankly delusional claims to be the sword
of vengeance of the Lord and thought
that he would sit at the
left hand of God in heaven.
It's the person seems not to
be well grounded in reality.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
after they take a look and
see what the diagnosis is,
the court finds that he's
incompetent for trial.
That is,
he cannot assist his lawyers
understand what's going on at trial.
And so he's committed to a hospital,
but not long after that,
uh,
the hospital reports that he's
now he's been taking thorazine,
which was the,
uh,
psychotropic drug often given at the
time that ache was in the hospital,
uh,
and that,
he is now competent for trial,
but the doctors did not examine him on
the question of whether he was insane.
That is whether he had
an insanity defense,
uh,
based on his mental health
at the time of trial.
So let's go to his trial.
Uh,
guilt phase.
He clearly did the crime.
The only question is,
was he criminally responsible?
That is,
could he appreciate the
wrongfulness of his behavior?
Uh,
and the law in Oklahoma at the time was
that it was on the defendants side that
that issue had to be raised and that
some doubt had to be raised about sanity.
If a doubt was raised by the defendant
and the burden was on the state to prove
it beyond a reasonable doubt.
But here,
um,
uh,
no expert testified on either side.
So there was no evidence with regard to,
uh,
aches,
sanity,
and therefore he was unable to
present his insanity defense,
uh,
at all.
And obviously this a case where it sounds
like that would have been at least a
possible defense in
the case penalty phase,
even more critical because they're,
the issue is future dangerousness.
Is He a future danger to society?
Uh,
prosecution has three psychiatrists
who testify that he is a ache,
has nobody.
Uh,
so in terms of the trial,
uh,
he has nobody to present and
supportive his insanity defense.
Nobody to present on the
question of future dangerousness.
His appeal to the United States Supreme
Court is that he's entitled to an expert
witness and an opinion
by Thurgood Marshall.
Uh,
the Supreme Court said
that he is entitled,
or that he has to have an adequate
opportunity to present his defense fairly,
uh,
within the adversary system using what
Justice Marshall characterized as the
basic tools,
uh,
of,
a defense.
Uh,
the court bounces three factors in
this opinion by Justice Marshall.
Uh,
the private interest aches,
interest,
obviously he has a compelling need
because he can't present it a fence and he
can't put on any evidence on future
dangerousness unless he has an expert.
So his need pretty,
pretty clear.
Uh,
the state's interest and Justice
Marshall rejects the notion that does,
is too expensive for the state to provide
a mental health expert for a state
could provide mental health experts,
uh,
for the prosecution.
Uh,
and it said the state has no
interest in this strategic advantage,
uh,
by denying somebody
the evidence they need,
uh,
to contest the issues in the case.
Uh,
so,
uh,
basically says finally
the public interest,
which is also kind of a state interest,
uh,
that,
the,
the state has an interest in these
issues being adequately litigated.
A and being reliably determined.
Uh,
Justice Marshall points out most states
provides psychiatrists or mental health
experts and in cases that there
is an issue of or a likelihood,
uh,
of,
inaccurate resolution,
uh,
in these cases that psychiatry
is not an exact science,
uh,
and therefore,
that ache is entitled to have evidence
to present on his side of the question is
basically it's a,
it's a descendant of
Griffin versus Illinois.
The case in which the Supreme Court
said that the two people from Illinois,
we're entitled to a transcript
for their appeal here.
The court much more realized
upon the due process clause.
While it does rely on the due process
clause and not equal protection,
but says,
as a matter of fundamental fairness,
the defense is entitled,
uh,
to present,
expert evidence in the
state has to pay for it.
But only in these situations
where it's a significant factor.
In Nick's case,
obviously it was a significant factor at
the guilt phase and sanity was the only
issue.
It was a significant factor
at the sentencing phase
where future dangerousness
was.
The only issue of course says there's
no right of the defense to select the
expert.
Of course the prosecutor selects the
experts that are going to testify for the
prosecution.
The right recognized an ache is basically
just simply a right of a defendant
through his lawyer to go to the court
and ask for an expert and the court can
appoint a whatever expert
the judge wants to a point.
As a practical matter,
most of the time the defense is
going to go to the judge and say,
this is the particular expert I need.
I needed a neurologist because this issue
is presented or I need a psychologist
because we need to do testing.
The need has to be set out.
Uh,
but one competent expert is all,
at least the constitution titles you to,
uh,
the expert can assist in
preparing the defense.
That is the defense may need an
expert to just simply look at what the
prosecution's expert is set and,
uh,
help the defense decide.
Is this something we can contest?
Uh,
perhaps after consulting with an expert,
the defense will conclude
that the prosecution is
right or the export is right,
uh,
and concede the point on the other hand,
it may be something that can be
contested and aix case clearly.
Uh,
the question of his sanity and the
question of future dangerousness were
probably subject to,
uh,
being,
challenged.
Uh,
Chief Justice Burger concurring says this
is limited just to a depth pony cases
and just the mental health experts.
But as a,
again,
as a practical matter,
courts all over the country,
state courts as well as
federal courts have recognized,
uh,
there is a need for funds for
all sorts of expert assistance.
It may be ballistics in a case where
there's a question about where the bullet
came from,
whose gun was it fired.
Uh,
it may be a bite marks in a case where
the state is putting forward that very
controversial,
uh,
evidence,
whatever the facts,
but it has to be a significant factor.
If it's not a significant
factor in the case,
then the court is probably not going
to be required to provide the expert
assistance,
uh,
but where it is,
where it's critical as it was an aix case,
uh,
then there's going to be,
the trial judge should order funding.
They're always going to be questions
far more than we can get into.
And in this brief session about
the adequacy of the funding,
uh,
often one sexpert start examining
a records and a defendant,
there may be a need to
do additional testing.
There may be a need for additional,
uh,
other experts to come in.
Uh,
all of those are issues that are going
to come up in cases from time to time.
Uh,
and the judges are going to decide these
as they come in and they're going to be
subject to appeal.
Very often the question on appeal is
going to be whether the defense made a
sufficient showing of neat and
are the words the defense shows.
This was a critical witness that
we had to have for our defense.
Uh,
finally,
generally an ache itself indicates
that this has to be made x party.
That is,
in other words,
just to the judge from the defense,
the prosecution is not involved and
the reasons for that are twofold.
One,
obviously a person of means a person
who could afford his or her own expert,
uh,
would not be required to reveal
who they were retaining and why,
uh,
to the prosecution.
The only reason that a poor person must
do it is because they're applying to the
court,
uh,
for the funding.
Uh,
the second reason is that often in order
to meet this very stringent standard of
showing of need,
uh,
the defense is going to
have to reveal to the judge,
uh,
communications with the client,
privileged communications
between attorney and client.
A is going to have to use a,
a reveal some of the work product,
uh,
that the lawyer has done.
These are the things that
normally are not ever made public.
Uh,
and so it would be very
prejudicial to the defendant,
uh,
if that information were
revealed to the prosecution,
the prosecution,
uh,
may at some point if the
expert is going to be used,
receive a report from the expert,
uh,
but as a general matter,
the basis for getting the expert,
uh,
is not going to be revealed
to the prosecution.
So this protects the poor
person in that situation.
Um,
let's talk for just a moment about
where and when people have a right to a
lawyer.
Uh,
we have talked about the right to
a lawyer at trial sixth amendment.
The constitution of the United States
says that every person accused of a crime
is entitled to a trial.
And the assistance of counsel at that
trial and the supreme court basically said
anytime a,
there's a loss of liberty,
uh,
there's a right to a lawyer and certainly
in a death penalty case where there's
a loss of life,
um,
there is a right to a lawyer.
Um,
but then the question becomes,
are you entitled to a
lawyer for your appeals?
Uh,
in,
uh,
the sixth amendment only applies to trials
the same day the court decided Gideon
versus Wainwright.
Uh,
the case that held that a poor person
accused of crime in a state court was
entitled to a lawyer at
State expense to defend them.
The court handed down a decision in a
case called Douglas Versus California in
which the court held that a person was
entitled to a lawyer for one appeal
and it base that not of course
on the right to counsel,
which only applies to trial,
but based on the case of
Griffin versus Illinois,
the case that had said there can be no
equal protection equal justice when the
kind of justice a person gets depends
upon the amount of money he or she has.
The court repeated that phrase,
uh,
later.
Nate versus Oklahoma.
We don't see that language again.
We only see the due
process part of Griffin.
Uh,
but later the court
decides in another case,
Ross versus Moffitt out of North Carolina,
that while a poor person has a
right to a lawyer for one appeal,
that in a state where
there's a second appeal,
let's say there's an intermediate
appellate court in the state and then an
appeal to the state Supreme Court.
No,
right to a lawyer.
Almost every state provides
lawyers at that point.
And remember estates can always do more
than what the constitution requires.
But Alabama for example,
does not provide a lawyer to seek review
in the Alabama Supreme Court only for
the first appeal to the Alabama
Court of criminal appeals,
even in death penalty cases.
Uh,
once the case has been
decided by the state courts,
either at the intermediate quarter
by the State Supreme Court,
a person can petition the United States
Supreme Court to review the case.
But there's no right to a lawyer for that.
So a poor person,
uh,
who's convicted and sentenced is going
to be dependent upon some volunteer
lawyer or perhaps if the state has a
public defender system or a capital
defender,
part of its role will be to represent
people before the United States Supreme
Court.
But in some states,
that's not the case.
But basically the constitution says
right to a lawyer at trial and one appeal
after the case is decided on appeal,
a person can file a petition for writ
of Habeas Corpus or file under whatever
vehicle the state provides,
uh,
for uh,
post conviction review where issues
like ineffective assistance of counsel,
jury misconduct,
uh,
the prosecution's failure to re
to disclose exculpatory evidence.
Those kinds of issues can be litigated
in a separate action because you may not
know about the prosecution's failure to
disclose exculpatory evidence and until
you become aware of it,
I went to the Lord becomes aware of it.
Uh,
normally ineffective assistance of counsel
can only be raised in post conviction
because obviously a person that's
defending a case can't raise their own
ineffectiveness.
They're trying to do
the best job they can,
but someone later may decide that the
lawyer was not competent and that in fact
the person was denied a fair trial.
Uh,
the sixth amendment right to counsel,
but no right to a lawyer
even in death penalty cases,
uh,
the court held sometime ago.
No.
Right.
For the average non death case,
no right to a lawyer for
this stage of the process.
And then in Murray versus Jaron Tonto,
even though,
and Tonto makes the argument,
this is definitely case
my life is at stake.
It's complex law and there's a very short
timeframe because I have an execution
date and I need to get into court in
order to file for a stay of execution.
Supreme Court says it doesn't matter,
it matters,
but it doesn't matter in
terms of a right to counsel,
uh,
that basically what Virginia was doing,
which was providing,
uh,
lawyers at the prisons to give advice
to people so they could follow their own
pleadings,
uh,
which of course it's totally
unrealistic in a capital case,
uh,
but that,
that was adequate.
Uh,
Justice Kennedy and a concurring opinion
also pointed out that in depth pony
cases,
people usually get lawyers from either
volunteer lawyers from law firms are
public interest organizations,
uh,
that represent them.
Uh,
some states do provide
lawyers either by providing a,
uh,
an organization,
a program that represents people,
uh,
in the post conviction process.
Uh,
but many do not.
and as a result,
uh,
people may be dependent upon a volunteer
lawyer to represent them at that stage.
Uh,
but basically a person
who's not synced to death,
uh,
probably has very little
ability to poor person.
Of course,
a person to means can hire a lawyer and
take advantage of the post conviction
review process.
But a poor person generally once their
case is affirmed on direct appeal,
unlikely that they're going to be
able to find a lawyer and raise a post
conviction.
A challenge to their conviction,
uh,
will cause they're not
entitled to a lawyer.
The state may not provide a lawyer.
Uh,
and there's a time limit.
There's a deadline,
uh,
which is going to vary
from state to state,
but can be as short as six months.
And as long two years.
But most people who are convicted and
particularly poor people do not have the
legal knowledge,
uh,
to raise these claims.
Finally,
uh,
every person sends to death finally has
an opportunity to present their case to
the federal courts,
um,
by seeking habeas corpus relief.
This final stage of the process,
uh,
the congress in adopting the federal
death penalty law provided that in capital
cases,
the federal courts can provide lawyers
to people facing the death Palette.
Some federal public defender offices have
capital Habeas units that is a part of
their office and specialized lawyers
who specialize in representing people at
this stage of the process.
Uh,
interestingly,
Texas,
the of the state that is executed over
well over 500 people has the most death
sentences of any state in
terms of carrying them out.
Uh,
does not have a capital Habeas unit
in any of the offices at the time.
Uh,
that,
uh,
that I'm talking.
Uh,
and uh,
but other places do,
uh,
Philadelphia,
Atlanta,
uh,
some and other places do not,
but,
uh,
the court can also appoint a lawyer.
Uh,
but generally the issues that are going
to be raised in the federal system are
going to be issues that should have
been raised as well in the state post
conviction process.
So hopefully,
uh,
the person has a lawyer
who's raised those issues.
They're presented the evidence because
the federal courts are going to look
pretty much at the record,
uh,
of what has been developed,
in the state courts.
So,
uh,
again,
non capital cases,
probably no lawyer for any of these steps,
capital cases,
it's going to depend on the state,
but only a constitutional
right to a lawyer,
a trial and one appeal.
And then whether or not their lawyers
at these other stages a statutory right
when they get to federal court.
But you've got this state
proceeding in between here.
There's a lot of variation
from state to state.
A and some states have done a very
good job of providing lawyers,
uh,
for people in post conviction
and other states like Alabama,
which was sort of called out by Justice
Ginsburg and maples versus Thomas and
Supreme Court opinion,
have really done almost nothing
at all to provide lawyers.
And,
uh,
the post conviction process.
So there's a great variance
from place to place,
but the lawyer,
the qualifications,
a little lawyer,
the resources lawyer,
all these things are absolutely critical,
uh,
to the review of death sentences and
the question of whether somebody is
sentenced to death,
uh,
but because of the crime they committed
and the circumstances of the crime and
the factors about the person or
whether sentenced to death though,
cause they had the misfortune of
being assigned the worst lawyer.
Yeah.